you know we have a we have a clip here
uh from the prom
and your character is very funny and i
what i love is the
the information that's laid out that
your character
uh is a struggling uh
a struggling actor broadway actor who
hasn't quite made it and so has to tend
barr
but um it's beautifully laid out that
you can't your character can't stop
talking about his time at juilliard
which does
feel like word would get around that's a
type that is definitely yeah
no i i dated a guy for many years who
went to juilliard and
they i'm not saying everyone
but i'm saying a lot of them like to
sneak that into conversation but the way
they do it
the way they do it is they say um their
group
number because it's not about the year
you graduated at julia right you say i
was in group
24 or i was in group which when that
when someone drops that into
conversation to be like well in group 13
i and you'd be like what is that and
they're like oh well at juilliard
i am perfect so that way they trigger
yes yes so i noticed that a lot i tried
to work that into
the film um but i think it was like a
little
too inside baseball to like have group
number
talk um but yeah that's a it's a real
thing it's like when people say like oh
i went to college in dc and you're like
just say georgetown like i get it
just say it and then they say no i
didn't go to college in jordan
i literally i went to a technical school
at two-year technical school in dc
[ __ ] yeah it was the university of
phoenix but it was
in dc we have a clip here uh from
the prom and i believe this is where
you're working the bar
you haven't made it yet uh but you're
quite a chatty cathy
with these massive stars that is true
all right let's take a look who are you
trent oliver uh oh
we've done five shows together oh really
yeah oh my god
trent went to julliard won't shut up
about it oh right
trend of course
why are you dressed like a waiter i'm in
between gigs at the moment
honestly d.d i feel adrift as i did in
my days
before juilliard oh my god you see it my
passions are fueled by the power of lady
theater and how she can with the
gentle touch of her head sculpt a human
soul
you know but we learned at if i could
soliloquize
if you prick me do i not bleed
the prom uh is available on netflix
friday and it's terrific and also by the
way
uh boys in the band is available to
stream on netflix right now
and it is also extraordinary
you're you're just you're you're killing
it you're hitting it out of the park and
i'm very happy for you
thank you thank you very much that and i
i don't know that there's a connection
but
i think me coming to check out
uh your performance in book of mormon
probably made all the difference in your
career
i think it did that's when uta called
was after you arrived
so um yeah because no one else was
paying attention to you or the
frankly the show
because you think franco said anything
about the show no he's too about franco
i called and i got the word out um
after it was already a huge hit that it
well thank you for that phone tree that
means a lot
by the way i will tell you that one of
the most controversial decisions my wife
ever made
was to take our two children
to see book of mormon and
at the time they were like 11
and 9 and i was like what the [ __ ]
she said it's such a it's good it's
really and i want it's fantastic
but there's vaginas and clitorises and
yeah well they've got to learn what a
[ __ ] is eventually so you know they
might as well
you know what i'm here to tell you you
don't need to know
i don't need to know
[Laughter]
you and me both